on savait pas que c'était des perroquets
au départ on s'est dit tiens pourquoi
pas un extraterrestre mais aussi mais là
on nous a dit madame on a là un peu trop
et donc du coup c'est vrai qu'on a
maintenant on n'a pas hésité on était on
était ravi de faire ça non mais alors et
il paraît je vous pose la question il
paraît que vous êtes payé pareil que
vous restiez tous les émissions ou une
fois c'est un candidat il a fait qu'il
va ça m'a dit de me faire sortir vite
parce qu'en fait tu payé pareil combien
je me permets de vous poser la question
comme vous êtes des amis en toute
transparence je design on les aime
beaucoup m'a pas dit que c'était
symbolique pour vous on m'a donné une
somme vous allez dire si c'est vrai de
40000 euros chacun pour la participation
aux faits 80000 symbole ça tu peux la /
nous déjà assez vain vie de chacun mais
oui d'accord mais avec 40000 lui mais
pour cette belle somme
c'est une info de salon c'est aussi
parce qu'ils avaient envie de chanter
les bonus ben oui vous êtes découvert un
passionnant comme pris de ride même
envie de chanter maintenant après bac
d'abord d'un oeuf
c'est terminé
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
premier contact au top c'est parti
d'accord alors allez-y ça fait dix ans
qu'elle le fait des gens oui allez-y
c'est ginette g l'acculent ginette sur
le nez j'essaye de passer incognito qui
hélas genre d'organisation c'est mauvais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
essai - est très bon c'est bon là la
fille de rené malleville la famille
laval et là c'est jean-michel mais non
mes potes mais non il s'est trompé au
kendo coach qui est là
ces phares toutes parts au quai par
toute première fois
[Applaudissements]
ces gens ton sur ton
oui genton c'est moi gerenton qui
j'entends le loup lé succès sur non mais
franchement je vous jure frange est sur
la sellette des enfants ça vous va hyper
j'aime beaucoup et non mais sans rigoler
terminons qu'elle sait quel avenir bien
sûr pour tp
c'est la question que vous posez ici
c'est la question que vous posez chez
vous eh bien je vais vous dire alors oui
il y aura une émission quoi qu'il arrive
oui vous ne serez pas payer quoi qu'il a
oui je vous accompagnerai voilà quoi
qu'il arrive avec les chroniqueurs
mais ici il est pressé avec ses gros
seins
[Rires]
oscar vous avez une belle poitrine
si mon film en total le couple le public
ne pourra plus être avec nous en plaques
malheureusement s'il ya un couvre-feu
plus tôt nous continuerons à recevoir du
public mais nous avancerons les horaires
de tournage de l'émission
voilà s'il ya un couvre-feu à 19 heures
on attendra les missions avant 17h aussi
et on conservera le public parce que
vous savez que c'est très important bien
sûr pour nous est que je suis très
heureux que vous soyez là serons nous
encore en plateau qu'il y ait un
confinement généralisée au pas nous
resterons quoi qu'il en soit en plateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande d'applaudir celui qui
est là c'est jean michel maire on va
voir tout de suite son costume en quoi
il est déguisé jean michel maire
[Applaudissements]
nous équipes d'être mais moi je m'en
bats les couilles vers ses coéquipiers
alors ils ont été battus mais ça hyper
bien pour moi de pastis dans mon bistrot
a donc trouvé une photo de boîtes
pleines de bord a dû passer castaldi et
laon coin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après momie ses basques
non
grasset et là bas voilà des sandales
maintien oui mais suis-je on s englué
mais c'est ça ça vous va bien en fait
merveille
oui mais non non mais je me demande s'il
faut pas faire un délires capillaires un
peu comme ça laissait un peu poussé on
va accueillir tout de suite qu'elle y
met nos vies
[Applaudissements]
je
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non
c'est dracula apparemment c'est dracula
est suspecte du sol
[Applaudissements]
je suis là comte dracula saiema et vue
web un jour ça vous va hyper bien ouais
et tous vous va vous aimez moi je suis
un top model jean-michel non non non et
non je trouve que tu as we annuel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors voilà c'est d'abord et zoran mais
y'a pas là vous n'êtes pas là par ben le
coup y accepter qu'il ou qu'elle puisse
fouiller votre téléphone
voilà le droit de fouiller dans votre
téléphone oui tout le temps ouais elle
elle peut cette question j'ai pris
toutes les précautions doivent
normalement non c'est bon il est clean
code non ajoutant est le tchèque de
croix sur des bateaux comme vous le
savez quand vous allez au restaurant qui
est le mec qui met sur téléphone comme
ça que bah oui parce qu'elle fait est
très lourd s'est ouvert tu parles moi je
le mets tout le temps comme ça
non moi aussi j'ai eu mal on perd
l'arrêté moi de mettre à l'envers
lorsque c'est louche
mais maintenant je le mets à l'endroit
en mode avion
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
khadir sur les modernités mon iphone on
the pros de mes couilles et ou social et
social je prends et s'allume ce qu'il
voit mon visage le problème c'est que tu
es connu le mec sur la terre riz picto
d'even sur un téléphone y fait bigard il
a ma gueule
mais en face de mon téléphone et ils
allument l'achète à vélo
merci d'être là philippe vraiment merci
et et on comprend vraiment votre
désarroi et j'ai vu plein de gens moi
aujourd'hui plein de potes quand on
débarque dans des restaurants qui est
que j'ai eues en pleurs au téléphone qui
m'ont dit si rien moi ces dix années
20-30 ans travail qui part en poussière
je sais que je me relèverai plus c'est
l'histoire d'une vie pour beaucoup de
gens beaucoup de familles ça c'est
terrible
imaginez vous la tous autour de du
plateau là vous êtes tous des bons
vivants imaginer qu'un jour de puissiez
plus jamais mangé au restaurant vont
aller boire un coup dans un bar qu'est
ce que vous feriez métro boulot dodo
c'est ce qui va se passer on va et le
lien social il va est rompue ça va être
terrible
alors on peut pas après rivaliser avec
la santé parce qu'elle est important que
la santé j'entends mais comment
aujourd'hui en 2020 on à avoir à choisir
entre la santé et l'économie
[Musique]